et sousse savait que la maladie road est
à madrid ils s'étaient informés sur les
réseaux sociaux pour connaître les
symptômes de la variole simienne la
fièvre les pustules sur le corps il y
prêtait attention il se croyait en
sécurité quand il a rencontré un jeune
homme avec qui il a eu une relation
sexuelle pour se tenir au même théâtre
arias et 6000 chameaux et les langues
lui ôter la police pour tenter grandi et
je m'accorde el hocine thomas la virole
ils doutaient encore puis trois petites
lésions sont apparus sur son corps
interne ce
qui
est local maroc
et octo comment fabriquer des cancers
freiner la propagation de la variole
simienne l'espagne a lancé une campagne
de vaccination pour les populations les
plus à risque il y a deux semaines
le pays a acheté douze mille doses de
vaccin contre la variole mais n'a pu en
recevoir que cinq minutes jusqu ici
les rendez-vous sont difficiles à
obtenir mais les volontaires eux sont de
plus en plus nombreux à aimer n'a pas
rendez vous mais il espère obtenir une
des 90 dos qui seront distribués
aujourd'hui
s'ils souhaitaient malgré ces efforts de
prévention qui me diront certains
l'espagne compte aujourd'hui plus de
4500 cas répertoriés de la maladie ce
qui en fait le pays d'europe le plus
touché est la variole simienne continue
de se propager rapidement partout sur la
planète ce qui a poussé l'organisation
mondiale de la santé fin juillet a
décrété une urgence sanitaire publique
de portée internationale son plus haut
niveau d'alert la dernière fois que le
ms avait lancé une telle alerte c'était
en 2020 pour l'aco vide
à l'échelle mondiale le msd compte
maintenant 27 mille cas de variole
simienne luis déplore l'absence de
communication claire des autorités de
son pays il a trouvé seul les
informations pour la vaccination sur des
groupes de partage et non sur les sites
officiels de la santé publique il croit
que c'est parce que la majorité des cas
touchent des hommes qui ont des rapports
sexuels avec des hommes
quant à
la taille et qui
ont collectivement simplement d'un
parquet elle patiente offert aux
partenaires et collectives et c1 et
protéger le breton entre
un roulant d'homophobie croit cette
militante des droits lgbt qu plus qui
risquent d'exacerber une crise de santé
publique
il faut dire plus clairement que tout le
monde est à risque croît telles
pratiques sexuelles
pour l'installer en affichant un contact
mr cannes et monaco notera personnes
indépendantes des soldats sexuelle
plus que la douleur celle isolement qui
réussissent à trouver difficiles avec la
maladie mieux si leurs intérieurs qui
est fermé la nuit à peine à la table
la peur et la honte jesús tente de les
surmonter pour prévenir dit il les virus
ne font pas de discrimination ici
marie-eve bédard radio-canada madrid